about to random debate is from
pseudo-random monkeys okay thanks Raghu
this is joint work with me honk who just
spoke to you and I'm gonna piggyback off
of a couple of things that he said I
want to thank the organizers for
inviting me to this workshop I tried to
really live up to the title by proving
and using me pseudo randomness I've
pseudo-random this twice in the title I
guess once is proving and once is using
so hopefully it fits the mission by this
point in the workshop I think we're all
pretty familiar with this notion of
pseudo-random generator so I'll go
through this first slide very quickly we
have some circuit class that we're
interested in and a PRG for the class is
just an efficient deterministic
algorithm that stretches short truly
random strings to pseudo random strings
which can fool all the circuits in the
class so you've got some kind of our bit
seed of compounder here the generators
deterministic it gives you an n-bit
output drawn from this distribution
which successfully fools every function
in the class whatever your circuit is
the difference in expectations or
acceptance probabilities is most epsilon
ok so we're in California we're dreaming
we wish that we had prgs for the class
of all polynomial size circuits but I
think all of us know that this is not
right around the corner right as Leon
mentioned if you have prgs against a
circuit class this means you have
circuit lower bounds against the class
and the fact you even have average case
lower bounds correlation bounds ok so if
we're interested in staying within the
realm of sort of unconditional pseudo
randomness and we don't expect to prove
new circuit lower bounds or correlation
bounds then we can only really hope for
prgs against circuit classes where we
have these things already circular
bounds or correlation bounds and that's
what this talk will be about it's
focusing on two specific classes where
we have circuit lower bounds and
correlation bands we really are going to
be trying to achieve and we will be
achieving kind of the best PR geez we
could hope for given the state of the
art and these harder problems with these
problems ok so I couldn't decide between
two introductions one was sort of
oriented around results and one was
oriented around techniques I decided I
give you both introductions and if
there's any time left we'll see what
happens so the results are introduction
entered the results oriented
introduction if you want to sort of put
this work in a nutshell or a bumper
sticker we get essentially the best
possible prgs for two well studied
classes of boolean funk
the best possible in the sense that
improving our results would require
getting better Circuit lower balance or
correlation bounds okay the two classes
are constant depth circuits and sparse
you have two polynomials and I'll start
by telling you about the results for
constant depth circuits so this is just
a c0 we've been talking about this on
and off throughout the workshop right we
all know what these circuits are and the
nor gates we measure the complexity of
the circuit the size just the number of
gates and the depth is the depth what do
we know about lower bounds for these
constant depth circuits which again are
sort of a barrier for pseudo-random
generators well the best the strongest
known circuit lower bounds are basically
exponential in n to the 1 over the depth
minus 1 so we have like two to the root
n circuit lower bounds for dep three
circuits so on and so forth given this
what can you hope for a while you sort
of Ben Burtt this easy argument that
tells you about prgs implying circuit
lower bounds the best prgs we could
expect without kind of you know breaking
through this barrier which likely young
said is 30 years old but i've seed let
something like this log of the circuit
size with an exponent of d minus one and
just logged one of our epsilon in terms
of the arrow parameter for the prg okay
so this is what one could reasonably or
you know without hoping for a real
breakthrough try to achieve prepare G's
for AC 0 okay so there's been a long
line of work on prgs for AC 0 Lee Jung
mentioned the site IV gerson work which
got the whole ball rolling we've talked
on and off about the nissans generator
which was sorry not me since January
this is basically the nissan figures in
paradigm so on and so forth the line of
results leading up to something quite
recently this year or this past year by
harsha and Srinivasa on let me just
highlight a couple of quantitative
aspects of these different results so
Lucas TRG the Travis on shrage a
pseudo-random generator for AC 0 for the
first time got the right dependence on
the size parameter right if you look at
the previous works we had something like
maybe log to the 2d or log to the d
squared or something like that Luca got
logged to the you know 1.0 times D so
it's possible to get the right
dependence on size this very recent
paper by harsha and Srinivasa and showed
for the first time that you can get the
right dependence on the error parameter
just log one of our epsilon as opposed
to if you look at all the other things
that you know one where epsilon is in
like a log to the day your log to the 2d
or something like
okay so you can probably guess where
this next slide is going what we do is
we managed to sort of get the best of
both worlds of these two previous
generators so we're not getting exactly
log to the D minus one its log to the D
plus some absolute constant but we have
kind of the right dependence on em you
know we're getting the right bound up to
the additive constant in the exponent on
the log and the right dependence on
epsilon and again it's as best possible
but that's modulo current circuit lower
bounds okay see the product not the sum
of these people look for the best
possible absolutely is in this
polynomial you need to lose another log
with these deese reductions from
coalition bonds with that the two lower
bounds for their p plus 1 yes so you're
saying it is the product yeah okay okay
I taking those words read less long when
where epsilon
if you can add you get something new
circle balance if you get a plus yeah I
think so if epsilon is yrics polynomial
the right bonus to be a lot to the big
be enticing right so there is it Peter
okay good we wait okay so that's we're
still in the results are ancient
production that's the results for AC 0
circuits we also can say similar kinds
of things for sparse F 2 polynomials so
just a little picture these are just
neither more nor less than parody of and
gates and we measure the size by the
number of and gates for the number of
monomials in the polynomial here we
don't have a lower bound as our barrier
it's trivial to have lower bounds right
every function has a unique
representation as an f2 polynomial but
the correlation bounds are a barrier
right that's sort of this long-standing
challenge there people who could make
very happy by giving correlation bounds
against Steph two polynomials of degree
more than log n okay if you think about
it degree log n over n variables that's
end to the login possible monomials so
we don't know correlation bounced once s
gets to end to the log n if you invert n
to the log in it turns out that sort of
the best prg we could hope for would
have seed length 2 to the square root
log of the sparsity okay and again with
this log 1 over epsilon we'd like this
is kind of you know the bench this would
be sort of the gold standard given
current correlation bounds for these f
two polynomials so again you probably
can guess where this is going in
previous work this is louisville a
quebec Vickerson they were able to get
the right dependence you know module of
this the correlation bounds on s but the
epsilon is not where we want it to be
it's hanging out up nip hanging out up
in the exponent instead of being down
below there was previous work on a
related class so low degree GF 2
polynomials instead of sparse GF 2
polynomials where they were able to get
the epsilon in the right place like a
log 1 over epsilon dependence down in
the bottom and what do we do we sort of
put these things together and we managed
to do it right with this correct
dependence on square root log s and the
exponent and log 1 over epsilon the best
possible dependence on epsilon down in
the base and I didn't really call
attention to this earlier but you may be
noticed over on the right-hand side of
the analogous slide for a c0 sort of
this highlighted you know business of
the techniques the new technique that
will be talking about to get these
results is d randomizing a multi
switching
and I didn't mention this a couple
slides back but the key technique of
luca's earlier work his prg was d
randomizing a non multi switching lemma
sort of a vanilla switching lemma okay
so that's going to be sort of the Delta
of what we do and if I get to any
technical content that'll be with the
technical contents about okay good so
that was the first introduction now for
a techniques orient introduction just
saying the same thing I said one second
ago the main sort of technical
contribution that we make is coming up
with a way to have a pseudo-random
variant of these multi switching lemmas
and throughout the talk I think I'm
going to be mostly referencing hostage
recent multi switching lemma from 2014
but essentially equivalent multi
switching lemma was obtained by apollyon
so Matthews in pittore I think you could
sort of use them indistinguishable
indistinguishably in the arguments which
is for concreteness I'll be referring to
hostiles stuff okay good so I'll go
through this the basics very quickly we
also will know and we'll saw from
Liang's talk what is a restriction of a
function it's just a way of fixing some
of the coordinates of the function two
constants leaving other coordinates
alive the standard restrictions and
people most commonly think about or
truly random restrictions these
quote-unquote RP restrictions were
coordinate wise independently you let
each variable survive with probability P
and fix it uniformly otherwise okay so
those are restrictions what is switching
lemons say they're just statements which
basically say that dnf switched to see
NFS when you hit them with a random
restriction or vice versa in fact
switching let us tell you a little bit
more sort of the most famous switching
lemma is Johan switching lemma from the
mid 80s which says if you have a case
enf and you you know want to sort of
analyze does it what happens when it you
hit it with a random restriction in fact
it collapses to a shallow decision tree
decision tree of some depth with an
exponentially decreasing probability
okay in this decision tree of course you
can think it was either a dnf for a CNF
so it gives you the kind of statement
about switching from DNFs to see an
absent vice versa sorry can you do my
latest addiction says justice direction
of the Costas coordinate wise
independent everybody stays alive with
probability P otherwise uniform constant
yes
okay and we don't touched on this too
and his talk sort of a nice thing about
this band is if you think about say
polynomial size CNF formula this starts
to kick in it tells you something once
when Pisa you know quite large it can be
as big as say one of our 10 log in or
something like that think of K is being
log in if the CNF is polynomial size
right and you'll have something like a
half which then decreases exponentially
in the depth of the decision tree team
okay so it's a nice thing about the
hostile switching lemma is that you know
it gives you sort of a meaningful
statement in this context for large p p
being one of your login okay well like
me out said we're not going to be you
know making much hey if you deal with
truly random restrictions in the context
to be randomization so we have to think
about pseudo-random restrictions right
and these are again just some
distribution over restrictions that's
more randomness efficient somehow you
don't have tossed so many coins to
generate one of them okay I time
vickerson were already using
pseudo-random switching lemmas to get
prg results these were sort of the first
bullets on the slides I showed you
earlier and luca and punkish way I guess
gave a optimal essentially optimal
pseudo-random switching lemma they were
able to dear Anne demise the switching
llama by so do this very clever approach
of fooling the proof and i'll talk more
about that later the sense in which i'm
saying it's optimal here is that you can
take kind of the same parameters and get
the same conclusion as the truly random
switching lemma he can handle a P as
large as like 1 over log n the same way
the genuine switching lie by the
original one could and being able to
handle such a lard p large p is one
ingredient that led him to this good
seed length in his prg for AC 0 okay and
there are other works which were
mentioned earlier giving in Liang stop
giving pseudo-random generators via
pseudo-random switching weapons okay so
in terms of techniques what do we do
it's maybe a little bit analogous to
Michael's talk earlier today when he was
saying you know you sort of take these
components of nissan's argument and you
do them in this new framework we're
going to be working quite similarly to
what Luca did but instead of D
randomizing the switching lemma right
we're going to be D randomizing these
recent multi switching lemmas are in
particular this recent multi switching
lemma of hostage okay so I got to tell
you a little bit about what is this
multi switching lemma and so on if we go
on in this talk which I guess we can
give them the time
so yeah this is not you know it's not so
simple as you prove this sort of
pseudo-random multi switching lemma and
you're done there are other ingredients
which have to come into play in order to
get the actual results in particular we
use the Site I Vickerson sort of
iterative chunk by chunk kind of
framework basically the kind of thing
Liang was talking about earlier and for
both our results it's absolutely crucial
that we have this Harsha srinivasa and
prg from last year remember these were
the guys who were first able to get just
a lot of one of her epsilon dependence
on the seed length and we explicitly use
that we rely on that in a crucial way
okay and there's some other ingredients
if you have two polynomials as well and
so on so just to remind you yeah most of
the rest of the talk I guess will be
about the D randomize the pseudo-random
multi switching lemma but just to sort
of say something about the other aspects
of the work I'll have one slide here
just reminding you hopefully it brings
back fond memories from before the
coffee break from Liang's talk you can
see it was stolen more or less from his
kind of slides in terms of the visuals
once well just a quick idea of like how
does the pseudo-random switching lemma
help us get a PRG right how does it work
well it's the kind of thing we saw
before a pseudo-random switching lemma
we have some pseudo random way of
filling in the stars ok and we fill in
the non stars in a truly random way a
pseudo-random switching lemma tells us
that such a restriction collapses say a
small CNF to a small with CNF to a
shallow decision tree with very high
probability ok so it's much the same
kind of thing we saw in the search
context but a little different we can't
sort of prune the search tree we have to
expand out the search tree at all levels
in order to get a pseudo-random
generator so we cycle through all the
different choices of a pseudo random set
of stars we cycle through all the
possible assignments to the variables in
the chosen set of stars assigning you
know according to some pseudo random
distribution that fools the functions
that come out of the pseudo-random the
pseudo-random switching lemma right so
we're sort of trying this said trying
this edge trying this set for each of
these sets we try all the possible
settings according to the pseudo random
distribution that fools decision trees
and then we have this branching right
for each one of these choices we proceed
to the next stage we fixed you know
these bits in some way and now we're
going to go on in the second stage will
fix another bulk of bits the very
similar in spirit to what we saw
Liang doing earlier okay I'm very
similar to what we saw Leon doing in
each single stage so this is a cartoon
of one stage in each single stage we
fill in a pre fraction of the
coordinates okay and where's Lee Jung
and hits it setting you just sort of
went for think of it as like 1 over P or
one of her p log n many stages to do
this approximate counting and it wasn't
an expensive thing even if we had to do
end stages that's just like a
multiplicative factor of N in the
running time now we're branching now we
have this branching factor so we really
do want to take P to be very large right
the more stages we have to do with this
the deeper our tree is and the worst you
know sort of the parameters of our
overall prg you're going to be so this
is why sort of peeking back and also
peeking forward it's very useful to have
something like Lucas pseudo-random
version of hostage switching lamb I
where we can take P to be quite large
okay that leads to strong parameters
good okay so we're done with both
introductions I think I wish I would
have left 15 minutes 14 minutes ok so I
can talk a little more the rest of the
talk i'm going to just focus for
concreteness on AC 0 I'll remind you of
sort of the stuff about the switching
Lima and basics about the multi
switching lemma which may be a little
less familiar we'll sort of give a quick
overview of how Luca was able to use a d
randomized version of the switching
lemma in order to sort you know how we
sort of able to come up with a d
randomized version of the switching lima
by fooling the proof of hostage
switching lemma to get his pseudo-random
switching my mind will I'll sketch at a
very high level how we're able to do
something now I guess fool the proof of
the multi switching Lima to come up with
a pseudo-random multi switching lemma
which turns out to have the kind of
parameters which give us the results I
said earlier ok so again switching
levels and multi switching lemmas we saw
already sort of a written out version of
hostile switching lemma tells us that
when you hit a CNF with a random
restriction a truly random restriction
it's very very likely to collapse to a
shallow decision tree it's very likely
that some shallow decision tree computes
it ok good and typically we're used to
thinking about this llama applying it in
the context of a c0 circuits where we
don't just do this once we do it a whole
bunch of times we have maybe D or D
minus one or D minus two stages of doing
this and we
in each stage we do it many times you
have something like if it's a size m
circuit you maybe apply it to you know
as many as M different depth cue
circuits two levels up from the bottom
okay so if you want to think about how
does the switching lemma play out in
this context of using it to do depth
reduction what ends up happening is that
essentially you need the error right or
rather I should say the failure
probability the switching lemma to be
something like epsilon over m if it's
something like epsilon over m then a
Union bound over the potentially M
different applications within a given
level will let you get something like an
epsilon failure probability out overall
but if you're doing it where the failure
probability something like epsilon over
m for single Fang this means you know
your exponent is going to be something
like log M over epsilon okay and if your
exponent is log M over epsilon after the
first stage well at the next stage now
when you apply the switching lemma you
know you're applying it to like a log M
over epsilon with CNF epsilon has kind
of crept into the picture at the next
stage the bottom fannin has this log M
over epsilon has a dependence on epsilon
and so your subsequent applications of
the switching Lama the second third
fourth time you're always going to have
a dependence on epsilon and pay in
particular p after D applications sort
of you know hitting it again and again
and again it will be something like log
P will be something like 1 over log M
over epsilon to the day this is not so
good right we don't want to have
something like a log 1 over epsilon to
the day we want to end up at the end of
the day with just a log 1 over epsilon
okay so this is just kind of a little
hand waving of why the original
switching level even then the truly
random version is not quite tailored for
the for our ultimate purposes of having
these optimal epsilon dependents good
okay so that's the original switching
lemma just the last couple of years
there's been this really cool work on
developing the so-called multi switching
lemmas these are like variance
generalizations of switching lemmas
which can analyze many CNF SAT once
under you look at a random restriction
and you say something good happens to a
whole collection of CN f's so to
understand what these same we need this
notion of a common partial decision tree
and it's a pretty straightforward notion
you've got a bunch of boolean functions
a decision tree is a common L partial
decision tree for this collection of
boolean functions if every function in
the collection is expressible it's just
that decision tree with a little bit of
extra stuff at the bottom
ticular depth L decision trees
augmenting it at the bottom so I think a
picture helps if this is my family of
functions f1 f2 through FM a common L
partial decision tree is just a decision
tree T such that i can write f 1 is this
decision tree with little depth l
decision trees glued on to the bottom
right it's common to all of them f to
the same treaty with different depth L
decision trees glued on at the bottom ok
so it's sort of does the brunt of the
work and you have to do a little bit of
cleanup you could think of it as like
the different depth felled trees down at
the bottom ok so this is this notion of
a common partial decision tree for a
family of functions the multi switching
lemma and again sort of referring to a
house Todd's version here but there's an
equivalent version of a yacht so at all
the multi switching lemma says what it
says well if you have a family of cns
and you hit that family with the random
restriction this is just saying the
worst CNF the worst function in the
family after a random restriction the
probability that you know any of them
don't have a common partial decision
tree of you know there's this log 2 m
depth for the extra parts you need
hanging off the bottom that's
exponentially small ok it goes down very
fast so you can think about applying
this multi switching lemma in a context
of AC 0 circuits and something much
nicer happens in terms of the depth
reduction now ok if you look at sort of
the picture that comes out you have an
AC 0 circuit originally you hit it with
the restriction what this says is that
you're very likely with you know all but
epsilon probability you end up as a
decision tree the depth of this decision
tree now is where the epsilon is hanging
out the log M over epsilon is the depth
of this tree down at the bottom you have
these circuits circuits c 1 c 2 and so
on you've done depth reduction and their
bottom Fanny and crucially doesn't have
any dependence on epsilon the bottom
fannin depends only on em okay and
that's important because it means you
can do it again you can hit right hit it
with another random restriction you'll
get down to sort of the first treaty won
a second treaty to and then circuits
have depth D minus 2 and so on but
you're never having an epsilon in the
picture for the bottom fannin of these
guys okay so in particular you run this
T times and your overall final value of
P will have no dependence on
epsilon right and that's a good thing
because we saw that we're going to pay
something like this 1 over P as in the
overall in the overall pseudo-random
generator ok so again this is just kind
of hinting at why the multi switching
lemma is maybe a useful thing for our
sort of context good these guys were
trying to get optimal correlation bounds
for AC 0 circuits yeah I guess ha stud
was going for correlation bands and the
other work if Russell is here you can
tell us the motivation was it counting
or satisfy like non-trivial
satisfiability science satisfiability
algorithms for AC 0 ok ok so with Luca
in the audience let me try to quickly
give a recap of how we thought of
trebizond Shui is working for this to
explain this I need to give you a little
bit of setup feels like a kind of wonky
notational thing but I think we sort of
need this are actually it'll be next
slide yet so yeah okay you're set up for
how Luca is able to prove his
pseudo-random switching lemma this is
maybe the most important part of any of
the slides there is this notion of a
canonical decision tree ok for a given
boolean for a given let's say CNF
formula we have this notion of a
canonical decision tree ok it's like a
particular way of computing the decision
trees to see Jesus computing the CNF is
a decision tree and it's just the
natural way that given a CNF formula you
would compute a decision tree right you
look at your CNF formula and if it's
constant 0 or the constant one throw
down zero or one that's the decision
tree otherwise you know you've got a
list of clauses there's like some fixed
ordering you look at the first sort of
non-trivial clause that isn't
identically one query all its variables
is your way of building you tree right
you've done some substitution so you can
simplify the other clauses now Andrew
curse at each of these leaves go on and
build the build the decision tree for
the remaining sub CNF that's induced by
that restriction so far ok so a very
simple kind of standard way of cooking
up a decision tree for a CNF it's the
first thing you think of if i gave you a
CNF and said you know write this as a
decision tree so if you look at what the
switching lima actually does the may be
stated earlier is a little weaker than
what it really gives you we stated it
before is saying you know if you have a
CNF and you hit
random restriction it's very likely that
it collapses to some shallow decision
tree what pasta is proof actually
establishes is that if you hit a CNF
with a random restriction it's actually
extremely likely that this decision tree
the canonical decision tree this process
of building a decision tree on the
restricted CNF gives you a very shallow
tree okay and this is crucial for Lucas
arguments he really exploits the
computational simplicity of this
decision tree construction procedure the
fact that this CD and at this canonical
decision tree is built in a very sort of
simple and straightforward way given
given given the function that you're
trying to build the tree for oh I don't
know this is a simple description of
simplicity it's just you know the fact
that you can you can look at this
procedure and you can analyze this
procedure you can sort of talk about
what this procedure needs to bear don't
mean like you need to understand the
computational complexity of going from
Indiana this is maybe a semantic
discussion which yeah let's take it
offline okay so to sort of instantiate
this show you this in a little bit more
detail I need again kind of a wonky
technical thing about you know encoding
restrictions as bit strings right it's
sort of something we have to do for this
to make sense so what's a restriction
it's a string of zeros ones and stars
okay if we want to talk about you know
sort of analyzing restrictions in our
kind of framework we need to think of
restrictions actually is you know bit
strings okay so there are many ways you
can do this this is a very natural way
of doing it I want to think about a 0 1
star string as you know I'm going to
interpret a sort of a binary matrix a
matrix of bits as 0 1 star string in
this natural kind of way right I look at
these first log 1 over P many rows of
the matrix and if I see that it's all
ones and all in a given row which
happens with probability P for each row
then I take the last row and I spit out
that bit then I actually give you a bit
value right so here I of 0 here we have
one because the last row is 1 here again
I have two columns of all ones I've 1
and 0 so i get 1 and 0 out for the
corresponding restriction and for
everything else and all the columns
where I don't have all ones in other
words a 1 minus P fraction of them I
just put down a star okay so it's just
sort of an example of simple procedure
by means of which you can kind of go
from a binary matrix like this to a
restriction so now we can notice
something very simple if I have a
uniform random binary matrix right well
then the probability for each coordinate
independently that I'm going to get the
bit value in the last row is just going
to be P so uniform random binary matrix
right would correspond to a truly random
restriction on the other hand if I have
some kind of way of constructing
pseudo-random bit matrices right pseudo
random elements of the space of all
possibilities up here that will in turn
induce some distribution some pseudo
random distribution over restrictions
okay and that's what we want we want
some kind of comp you know randomness
efficient distribution over restrictions
because that's that's what we're going
to be able to deal with so this is kind
of the crucial claim i think in lucas
work it says what it says that you know
kind of since this canonical decision
tree construction is so simple it's
possible to show actually that there's a
very simple circuit a depth three
circuit which outputs one given as input
the description the sort of bit string
describing the restriction it opens one
if and only if that restriction is a bad
restriction a restriction which leads
the canonical decision tree to have
large depth okay I'm just you know it's
really just an or the glimpse a little
bit behind the curtain the step three
circuit is an or over all possible paths
that could be long paths in a decision
tree okay so we just have again in
pictures some very simple circuit a
depth three circuit here which given an
encoding of a restriction and outputs
one if and only if the restriction sort
of contributes to the failure event of
the switching lemma okay and that's good
because it tells us hey you don't need a
truly random distribution over
restrictions you really it's enough to
have the pseudo random distribution that
fools depp three circuits step three
circuits are sort of all that you've got
a fool in order to be able to make this
go through okay so Luca exploits that he
right this is sort of a more technical
apologize it's so technical just read
the highlighted stuff his kind of man
lemma says if you have any distribution
that
these depth to circuits corresponding
it's a technicality def 2 verses step 3
corresponding to these deep pads in the
decision tree a distribution a pseudo
random distribution and cut over in
coatings of restrictions like that
suffice is to give you a hostage
switching lemma kind of conclusion you
can see we're exponential and T here and
so you know you can really plug in any
kind of pseudo random distribution over
restrictions that satisfies this fairly
mild property of fooling depth cue
circuits it happens to be as all you
need okay so you do this D times this is
like one level of depth reduction you do
d times and you get depth reduction for
an AC zero depth d circuit okay so this
was kind of a high-level overview of
Lucas stuff in the last minute or two
I'll just sketch very very quickly our
multi our pseudo random multi switching
lemma which does something analogous but
we have to do it now for the multi
switching lemma instead of the switching
lemma so it's a lot of fun if you want
kind of an analogy to walk us through
this right when we first talked about
the switching lemma we said hey the
probability that you're restricted
function does you know needs it isn't
computed by some small decision tree is
extremely small your restricted function
is probably computed by some very small
decision shallow decision tree but then
the real deal right sorry let me doing
it in this order yeah so this is for the
original switching lemma right probably
there's some diselo decision tree which
computes your restricted function the
multi switching lemma the way we
describe that a couple of slides ago was
saying hey if you've got a collection of
these see NFS then you know with very
high probability probably there's some
shallow common partial decision tree
that works for those guys okay but we
saw then that in fact what the toss that
switching lemma really gives us and what
Lucas argument exploits is the fact that
it's not just that there's some decision
tree right which works you know which is
a shallow decision tree for the
restricted CNF there's actually this
particular one is computationally simple
on this canonical decision tree probably
that is extremely shallow and similarly
we need something exactly analogous I
think it was a variant of hostiles multi
switching lemma which says that there is
some canonical common partial decision
trees like concrete one that has you
know an explicit description of how you
with it given the family of cns which
gives you a shallow common partial
decision tree for a family of cns so
what is this canonical com impartial
decision tree it has some definition I
encourage you not to read the definition
we just did a high-level intuitively
it's the kind of thing you would think
it's some way of plowing through the
CAF's one after the other you know
printable the decision tree as you go
along it's some like in a wealth
specified way of cooking up the decision
tree okay and so we do something
entirely analogous very closely
analogous to what Luca did we have to
analyze now this canonical common
decision tree construction procedure
which you can see is more involved in
the original just common a canonical
decision tree construction procedure but
we're able to come to a similar kind of
conclusion at the cost of one extra unit
of death okay instead of a depth three
circuit it turns out that now you have a
depth for circuit which you know
recognizes bad restrictions outputs one
if and only if the canonical partial
decision tree turns out to be deep okay
and there's something crucial here it's
sorry the crucial thing will be on the
next slide so this is very you know very
much as before it we don't need to have
true randomness for our underlying
encoding of just of restrictions it's
enough to have a pseudo random district
pseudo random distribution that fools
sort of the circuit that does this
recognition right enough to have a
pseudo random distribution that fools
this depth for circuit okay so this is
where crucially you're wondering maybe
where Harsha and sreenivasan you know
log 1 over epsilon seed length prg going
to come in this is absolutely where that
comes in so right this is sort of
analogous to Lucas earlier statement as
long as you have a distribution that
fools these step three circuits okay
then you'll get a conclusion similar in
spirit right the same kind of
quantitative thing exponential and T
everywhere you'll be able to then you
get that the canonic the canonical l-com
and partial decision tree the
probability that that is you know deeper
than some teased inverse exponential NTA
so this is exactly the kind of thing you
want but you've got to be able to fool
this class of depth recirc 'it's right
if we want our overall seed lamp to be
just logarithmic in 1 over epsilon you
got to be able to fool depp three
circuits with log 1 of r epsilon
but fortunately thanks to harsh and
Srinivasa and this is exactly the
technology they gave us right they had a
pseudo-random generator if you recall
from earlier which I guess now the D
that we would be plugging in for them is
three right because we're just fooling
these depp three circuits so we have you
know this is just some absolute constant
I guess it's nine or maybe a little bit
larger than nine but the dependence on
one of our epsilon is just a single log
1 over Epsilon okay so that's how we're
sort of able to get an overall
dependence of log 1 over epsilon and our
in our construction so the takeaway I
think amount of time is that there's a
techniques oriented take away a
results-oriented take away the technique
was developing a pseudo-random analog of
the with multi switching the
pseudo-random analogue for multi
switching lemmas of Lucas pseudo-random
pseudo-random you know regular switching
lemma and by using that together with
you know the site a bigger sent approach
and Harsha sreenivasan played a role
we're able to get these essentially
optimal pseudo-random generators for AC
0 for sparse of two polynomials we're
not going to really be able to improve
the parameters unless you can get some
kind of you know very strong and
exciting new results for correlation
bounds or circuit lower bounds okay so
that's it thank you some of your
high-level questions so you're kind of
saying that the TRG implies kara for
best less upkeep lower bound yeah
sometimes the particular seed lines and
kind of implicitly by working car on a
case-by-case basis you can go in the
reverse direction use it any hope to say
something general it's also I think it
depends on how finely you want to slice
the onion and write something like the
new some vectors in generator is you can
think of it as like a generic way of
going from correlation bounds to circuit
lower bands but you're not going to get
you know really these like exactly
matching parameters harsha and Sweeney
Bossa and have a nice explanation of
this I think you you know for a lot of
classes like AC 0 for
I think sparse have two polynomials and
other things you're not going to get
better for instance than like a log
squared one of our epsilon dependence on
the seed left and it doesn't you know it
doesn't seem like there's a way to get
better than like a log to the 2d
dependence on the sides for AC 0 and so
on so you know that is something like a
general so much general you know tool to
go in the other direction but it's not
maybe going to be enough to get you
really the sharpest results you could
hope for yeah one phrase which I didn't
use in this talk but which maybe 11
could use in this context is like you've
got some sort of computational hardness
from these you know you've got some
hardness from these circular bounds or
correlation bands and you want to sort
of convert all of it into pseudo
randomness and get like the best pseudo
randomness you know that the optimal
parameters out that you could hope for
so that's sort of you know with our
approach it seems you have to put these
these bunch of different ingredients
together for that
[Applause]
Russell